[Music]
hey what's going on and happy holidays
hot ones fans this is shawn evans
checking in for quite frankly
my favorite video of the year it is the
end of season
end of year hot ones fan q a we have our
stockings above the fireplace
our hot sauce is above the mantel and
then of course the bucket
full of your hard-hitting hot ones fan
questions but before we get into the
mailbag
i need to make an announcement hot ones
and first we
feast we have partnered with the common
threads charity to provide healthy meals
and cooking classes to families in need
we celebrate food and in the case of hot
ones maybe a little bit of gluttony but
the lack of access to nutrition facing
so many children in this country is
something that can't be ignored
as someone who's been documented on
camera failing to crack an egg i can
fully get behind the common thread's
mission to not only provide healthy
meals and snacks
for their students but then to also
provide hands-on cooking
instruction nutrition education that
these students can then take
and use in the long term to make healthy
lifestyle choices
not only for themselves but also their
households and also their
communities and to ensure they reach
families in need common threads partners
directly with schools and organizations
and under-resourced communities across
the country
where 80 or more of the students qualify
for free reduced lunch
and they're doing this in 12 major
markets across the country
including pittsburgh los angeles houston
new york my hometown of chicago so if
you're sitting there
watching this and you're thinking hey
sean you know i watch you
torture celebrities on hot ones every
week how can i also help out the kitties
well you know what i'm happy that you
asked right next to this video you'll
see a donate button
and it's been an impossible year like
the worst year
but just a few dollars really does
stretch a long way with this
cause in fact a donation for 25
that is going to be a groceries for the
week's worth of educational lessons
and then two dinners for a family of
four so if you were to donate 25
that's the impact it would have smash
that donate button if you can and
together
we will change the future through food
common threads
check it out read more donate if you can
but now we are on to the mailbag
these are your hard-hitting season 13
hot ones fan questions and to open it up
so why did this season lose the last dab
almost no one did it it's customary to
put a little extra dab of sauce on the
last wing and shawn certainly didn't say
it to the guests as part of his usual
script
what the [ __ ] well alright so here's the
thing with these remote episodes
there's no quality control so we send
the sauces over there and everybody's
just over
dabbing all of their wings already so
you know on the studio
dom tosses the wing the only time that
we're putting a little extra on the last
wing is with the last dab it's tradition
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah
but here on these remote episodes
everyone's dumping
half a bottle onto their wings and then
at the end
they're like dumping half the bottle of
last dab all over the place then what am
i supposed to do be like oh by the way
it's traditional on your put a little
extra on the last wing it's just like
confusing and clumsy and like
way extra on this one like more than i
have on the last ones or wait what what
but and then meanwhile i'm like over the
internet like
no well like if you've seen the show
before like we do on the last one right
it's just like it's too much to try to
shove into that
box so you know we just get there that's
that's how that goes
last trap last dab tradition it will be
back
uh but during the remote episodes it's
just like a little bit
like clumsy and all over the place
because people are just popping over
popping open bottles on the spot all
right
from haley ennis as a fellow u of i and
college of media alum i'd love to know
what's your favorite class
and what your favorite bar was quick
shout out to gully's
spent a lot of time at firehouse station
but the bar i think
of when i think about my college years
cams and then believe it or not this
year they have a mural
on the side of cams they have a little
sean walk in a last dab bottle
so huge honor forever grateful and then
my favorite classes were like the 400
level broadcast journalism classes
because they used to do
these live broadcasts with the students
and they were always a disaster like
that boom goes the dynamite kid that was
like every
single week would be like a bunch of
boom goes the dynamite moments
just kids trying to work with equipment
from the 80s put on a live broadcast
they get shot over to whether they're on
green screen they freeze
if that were on youtube if these sort of
like student
live news programs were on youtube they
get like millions and millions of hits
but they were my favorite so much fun
shout out to john paul
if he's still there all right up next
from
ethan mcgrory how does carrying out this
job satisfy what you want out of your
own work
hedy so in my head i'm a very i'm a very
simple man
like i could probably just you know go
running in the morning and then
watch college football and wait to die
that could be my life but i think what
this
show does is it has made me a more
worldly person because i get to walk a
mile in someone else's shoes every
single week so it's always mixing it up
one week i'm reading a neil degrasse
tyson book about astrophysics
the next week i'm watching the entire
filmography of daniel radcliffe
the next week i'm deep diving the
economics of combat sports to get ready
for an interview with ronda rousey
and i think the thing that's made this
last so long is actually just
love that process i enjoy that process
it's exposed me to so much music
that i wouldn't have otherwise listened
to so many movies that i wouldn't have
watched otherwise
so many unique stories and personalities
that maybe i wouldn't have known
so i owe that all to the hot ones
process and that's what i hope
i hope i'm getting out of it all right
next question
otaku games asks well i bet almost no
one is gonna say this
how are you doing
thank you for asking i'm doing i'm doing
pretty good
i'm doing pretty good kind of staying in
the routine
trying to stay busy uh singularly
focused
which isn't always easy to do especially
in these times
but i'm doing okay i'm doing okay thank
you
thank you so much for asking all right
next
from joel embiid
hey sean love the show what's on your
wishlist for the holidays
well joel embiid if that is your real
name
i'm a simple man i don't need much for
the holidays but i do like a good
surprise and speaking of surprises
camera guy bill i hear i have a very
special package
to sean from joel embiid let's see
what's in the box
joel embiid's hot habanero hot sauce
a hot sauce made with habanero with joel
embiid's face on it
everyone knows i like a little citrusy
heat i can see that working
and then we also have in here what else
we got in here
a mountain dew cookbook the big bold
book of mountain dew
recipes celebrating 80 years of paying
tribute to fans with a cookbook full of
recipes featuring dew
let's see what we got in here brine
turkey and stuffing
key lime pie bars pancakes
mountain dew pancakes
two cups of buttermilk complete pancake
mix and waffle mix
one cup of mountain dew i'll have to try
that out
thank you so much joelle embiid i will
cherish
the sauce and the mountain dew cookbook
forever
camera guy bill can you please put this
in my dressing room thank you so much
all right let's get back to the
questions
bob the builder asks pick three cheap
sauces that a college kid could get to
make their own mini gauntlet
so my immediate reaction to this
question is to suggest maybe like
looking at old hot ones episodes because
before we knew
like what the hell we were even doing we
would literally just go to the store
pull sauces off of the shelf and then
make the lineup that way so
i would suggest maybe looking at old hot
ones episodes but i get it
this is the end of year fan q a you need
answers i get it so off the top of my
head
your grocery store in town it has to
have frank's or texas pete's on the
shelf
that's a good number one frank's or
texas pete's and the number two
spot el yukateco has some hotter
sauces and you can oftentimes find the
pain as good line if you look around
pain as good as around there what's
every once in a while and then finally
the super hots and this is where it gets
tough because
most normal grocery stores are not going
to have
super hots but but
every once in a while if you got a
supermarket that's that's cool
they'll have a blair's or they'll have a
mad dog blares or mad dog
that's a good way to end it so frank's
el yukateco
mad dog or blair's three sauces
cheap easy to pick up at the store you
heard it here first
all right up next reverse roles now
you're the one being interviewed who
would you like to host your interview
let me start by saying you know i don't
know if i don't know if i need an
interview
i'm much more comfortable on this side
of the table than the other side
but i would like to take this time to
shout out some people
uh who i either idolized growing up or
have a tremendous amount of respect for
now
uh david letterman of course if you
watch hot ones
you know i love dave uh nardwar of
course
uh shout out the king tierra gross said
npr
batting average outrageous barely ever
bricks and then i think this is kind of
out there but i think the the best
interview with me would probably be with
speedy and jinx just the the the og
complex sort of uh talking heads thing i
think that would probably get the most
out of me
and then i do want to shout out quickly
uh taylor lorenz
who maybe not an interviewer but reports
and unpackages
internet goings-on probably better than
everyone else doing it
so shout out to taylor lorenz nardwar
letterman terry gross jinx and speedy
all right up next abdullah clark on
youtube
asks show us a picture of when you had
hair
alright colin roll the tape look at that
gorgeous head of hair
here i am i don't know freshman
sophomore year of high school
look at that look oh hey high school
football picture
look at all that hair on whoa this looks
like a young adult
sean with hair proof that it happened
and there you have it a lovely sean with
hair montage for you
all right just a few more questions in
the bucket
alxg dot co asks lebron james michael
jordan or kobe bryant
who do you think could handle the hot
wings challenge
i love the question kobe bryant in my
head the best interview of the bunch so
cerebral
so multi-faceted i say this as
a kid that grew up in the chicago
suburbs during the 90s michael jordan's
never doing this show
in a million years so what's even the
point of discussing it and then lebron
james the lebron james
is a name that you know we tracked down
or tried to track down
like keanu reeves or dave grohl like
just he's
he's white whale status so maybe someday
uh bron braun in the hot seat but i
guess only
time will tell last question
of all the celebrities who shot the show
from home who do you think had the
coolest setup
alright i absolutely love this question
i uh i'm gonna put them all into
different categories so to me
most on-brand household has to go to the
undertaker
and that headbangers ball mansion and
then jessica alba an extremely
jessica alba setting for her hot ones
appearance naomi campbell
is a setup that looked most like the
modern day for
psy matthew mcconaughey watch this again
you won't be able to un-watch it
he has an enormous fish just swimming
around
doing laps in that koi pond behind him
so for the outdoor setting
and then the koi fish b-plot matthew
mcconaughey definitely deserves some
accolades
coziest couch i have to give to brie
larson
and then special shout out for
recreating the set
to lil nazex thundercat ronda rousey
and drew barrymore well there you have
it another hot ones fan q as in the
books thank you so much at home if you
sent in a question thank you so much
for watching now rocking with us through
13 seasons of hot ones
in the next few weeks we'll have some
fun stuff coming out a little this
a little that and of course as you know
with hot ones when one season ends
the next one is right around the corner
but in the meantime
i hope that you enjoy the holidays i
hope that you enjoy this time
i hope that you're surrounded by friends
by family
by loved ones but if you're not i love
you
happy holidays
i want a mountain dew cookbook and i
want it signed by bill
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement
hot ones truth or dab the game is
finally here baby
what's in the box what's in the box
what's in the box
well the kit comes complete with 250
question cards
and then here's how the game works you
just go around the table
you take turns being the host being the
players and when you're a player you get
asked a question you have a choice
just like in the show answer it honestly
or suffer the wrath of the last dab and
take a look at this
there's even a mini bottle of the last
dab included i suggest you have napkins
on hand
you have to have some milk on hand and
of course be
careful be very careful around the eyes
hot ones truth or dab the play at home
game is available at
shop.firstweaves.com
heatness.com and amazon play at your own
risk
wings not included
[Music]
[Music]